they talk about a bad day at work this
is another kind of work rage the Belko
experiment so the Belko experiment
starts out in this building this office
building in the middle of butt-fuck nova
right there that's a red flag if you're
in it pretty expensive pretty
put-together office space in the middle
of nowhere you run for your life this
shit's going to go down and as
everyone's doing la-dee-da work is good
john c mckinley plays the creeps but
life is good the place locks down like
blast shields come over all the windows
all the doors seal off no one can get a
cell phone signal his voice comes over
the intercom it's like hello everyone
you're part of an experiment X amount of
people need to die otherwise we're going
to kill twice as many and then when they
find out these people mean business
that's pretty much what it is a bunch of
people locked into a building and they
have to kill each other off or be killed
but I'm not going to let you hear that
in this movie could have been a
fascinating social study it's not at
that point hopefully it's it's
fulfilling enough guilty-pleasure
gorefest film so what I liked about
Belko experiment ultimately is the
premise you hear the premise you're like
yeah that could go one of a hundred
different ways depending on what you
want to showcase in this movie but this
movie never really takes that dive into
being interesting fascinating asking the
question this movie never really takes
the plunge to take an average ordinary
person and make them a killer because of
the situational circumstance I mean you
could argue it happens with a couple of
people but not really generally speaking
in the movie the ones you could pick out
like alright in a situation like this
that person that person that person
they're going to get alpha male dick and
they're going to try to alpha male dick
everybody and kill people and in the
movie those wasn't do this movie also
has some cheesy as dialog overacting in
some bizarre as cartoon characters like
John C McKinley right when you meet him
you're like you're creepin out but
you're you're a cartoon creep and if
that's what the movies going for great
but it just it's not funny enough to
actually be satire just watch it you're
like this looks like it's the makings of
a bad movie kind of like some of these
people in the movie they're bad actors
they're just extras who like this guy's
supposed to be crying because he's
really stressed out but his cry is so
cartoon cry which again would work if
this movie was funny or clever enough to
be satire or a comedy not like there's a
stoner dude who always says man like
man they're putting it in the water man
I'm like what are you a 90 is stunners
what year does it take place
I'll have droid some cellphone so it's
not the 9news so totally speaking it was
just up down and all over the place when
the goes down it's actually pretty
entertaining and that that's where it's
just guilty-pleasure territory like have
a couple spirits with somebody's like
hey let's watch Belko experiment then
you watch it you get out you're like all
right cool we watched Belko experiments
like the dicks are dicks the nice people
are passive and the people in the middle
are conflicted but that's what it is
none of the nice people really become
conflicted or maybe dicks and none of
the dicks really become conflicted and
then maybe nice people there is a
character who is in the middle but he's
one of the conflicted and he doesn't
really it doesn't really give you the
juice you want I don't know this movie
was skimping on budget but the scale of
it just doesn't feel as big as it wants
to be like the intercom plug there are a
hundred and something off people who
work in those office building you're
like I count about 23 but okay a hundred
and something but I think this would be
totally all over the place here it is
right here
it's like Belko experiment wants to be a
dark comedy but it's not funny enough to
be a comedy so it can't be a dark comedy
it wants to be an interesting social
study on the boundaries of humanity and
where does martyr lie on it when it
swings for the spectrum of cheesy so
often that it can't be that because it
doesn't take itself seriously enough to
be that or maybe it's just a fun guilty
pleasure movie with bad acting because
that's what it's going for
I can't peg this film anywhere but if I
had to assess I'll say the movie does
not succeed and what it tries to do
there's one arc in particular that
doesn't go anywhere like you think
there's going to be big payoff to this
arc and in the end that person just gets
killed and it's done and over you can
tell it wants to be ironic like yeah but
that's the point
anybody can die but you don't think that
you're just left with that well what the
was the point of concentrating on
that person ever if you're like any time
spent on that character was just wasted
time like they were a time thing because
in the end the Belko experiment was
interesting enough if you can just turn
your brain off and enjoy the gorefest
that you're about to get don't go into
this movie looking for all the acting to
lend I feel like this is kind of what
the first purge mummy did had an
interesting premise didn't execute it to
its fullest the flaws really brought
down the entirety of the film hopefully
for the sequel they listened to fan
feedback for the first movie and they
make a sequel that we can sink our teeth
into that says the second person movie
was for me
anyway I enjoyed it however for the
Belko experiment I will say it'd be a
better time if you're drunk
yeah no it's a party right guys it's a
Belko experiment have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]